quand arrive quand je t'appelle trop mal
pourquoi je suis mis à part pour changer
de vue je veux davanture je veux du rêve
la chambre le bureau la salle de bain
avec la baignoire sabot comme à l'époque
me dis qu'on mange dans la baignoire ça
se fait plus en plus on peut pas habiter
avec wagner ger alors tu l'aimés 150
mètres carrés on trouvera jamais
qu'est ce tu fais là je vais me
rencontrer mes nouveaux collègues tu as
peur de craquer c'est sa maman
moi je m'en fous que julien sait les
texans j'ai réfléchi ça va c'est pas
comme si je n'avais jamais vu un poil en
fait et ledit dufau sa meuf je vois pas
ce que ça prend pas les gens ici et je
suis un peu perdu aucun match à domicile
en france a été client heureux
non pas que tu fais le fort sortons bull
qui perd demain je veux voir tout ce
qu'elle fait tu peux m'abonner mais
aussi pour mon jeu devient coin vip aux
landes danseuse étoile c'est ça qu'on
devient 45 manière générale c'est quoi
ça me joue comme moi révèle que je porte
leur fin de séance tandis que celle
influenceurs et alors marc gibert le
business appel au but c'est cool d'être
amis
page ne sent pas de faire du mal qu'est
ce qui se passe au spa de la fac je sais
pas si je fais la bonne bourre tube ma
gueule elle n'a jamais à l'école donc ça
un petit peu de succès tout comme ça
c'est quoi le problème on est passé d'un
portail mauvais d'accord avec elle c'est
ça mais ça va pas quoi
[Applaudissements]
si tu regarde un peu autour de toi tu
fais un cap plein de gens qui t'aiment
moi je t'aime et je t'aimerai toujours
je suis là depuis le début
c'est très gênant si l'homme se passer
[Musique]